wedding bells are ringing for Chris
Pratt and Katherine Schwarzenegger yes
it was the whirlwind romance we never
knew we needed after just seven months
of dating Chris proposed to Katherine
Hugh you guys I love it the actors
shared the exciting engagement news on
Instagram writing a sweet Katherine so
happy you said yes I'm thrilled to be
marrying you proud to live boldly in
faith with you here we go
so a source just shared with us how
Chris popped the question a source tells
us Chris was very sweet when he proposed
to Katherine as he had a romantic speech
prepared explaining how important she
was to him Chris fell really fast for
his new fiancee the couple was spotted
out the same day that him and
unofficially settled their divorce back
in November 2018
yeah source previously told ET quote
Anna and Chris have always maintained a
respectful relationship after breaking
up from the beginning their main focus
has been their son Jack Anna and Chris
support each other in their new
relationships and want one another to be
happy so Katherine seems like she's
going to make a great bonus mom can't
wait to see that all play out with Jack
I know she seems so sweet and really
loving and doting and I really like it
and I also kind of like she's not really
posted about Chris on her Instagram like
kind of private and girly savoring that
she has just good motherly qualities a
source adds Anna and Katherine have met
a few times and get along and that was
very important to Chris Anna is excited
for Chris and Katherine and above all is
happy Chris's with someone who loves
Jack like their own okay now a source
tells et Chris and Catherine are engaged
and couldn't be happier since the two
started dating it has always been easy
for them I believe that God works in
mysterious ways and gives us signs and
gifts in life and those gifts oftentimes
come in the form of people less than a
year later Chris seemed to find the best
gift in his soon-to-be wife
here's a timeline of Chris and
Catherine's summer romance in June 2018
they were spotted out for the first time
together on a Father's Day picnic how
cute is that
that and then et caught up with Chris a
day before that holiday where he dished
on his low-key plans fathers days
tomorrow how are you going to celebrate
church and I'm gonna I'm gonna lay low
and and swim in the pool that's what
we're gonna do okay so here they are in
August 2018 looking inseparable after
bike riding in Santa Monica no big deal
no big deal just cutie patooties Chris
who officially separated from Anna in
August 2017 made it Instagram official
with his leading lady in December 2018
in honor of her 29th birthday it's nice
to have your family with you because it
it it brings you to earth it brings you
down to earth and when you're when you
can touch you leave your feet on the
ground you get to actually experience
what it feels like to have your head in
the clouds now we have to imagine that
they're both on cloud nine with this
engagement news so exciting and someone
else who's happy is on a ferris wheel
actually commented on their picture
saying I'm so happy for you both
congratulations with a ton of
exclamation points look at that friendly
exes great news I mean it's just a win
all around now our source adds Chris had
the approval of the family and everyone
is excited for their union thank you
guys for watching for all the latest be
sure to subscribe to all things ET and
until next time I'm at Kourtney
underscore tezo know and I'm at Hawley
underscore Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]